if there's ever been a topic made for
talk radio debating taxing the
unvaccinated may be it krista what do
you say it should be at least three to
four hundred dollars it shouldn't be an
amount there should be a percentage of
an income that the people having when
smoke became a second-hand smoke issue
we banned it right this is not something
new because a covid would be fair
quantify how much of a burden these
people are back they get some flu are
placed on the health care system people
need a sedentary lifestyle people eat
fast food and then make it fair tax them
to and we get rid of the universal
health care system all together and be
fair about it
while quebec's proposed anti-vaxx tax
may only apply to quebecers the debate
is affecting canadians across the
country dave what do you think about
lego the issue as they say lit up the
lines in toronto yeah i don't like it
with some nervous about a slippery slope
and what could come next
it frightens me and others applauding
the quebec premier's tough approach he's
angry he's probably frustrated he has a
lot of guts so
like it or not i respect the man for
that
in vancouver different conditions but
the same questions a recent poll found
about 60 percent of canadians would
support some sort of a health surcharge
for the unvaccinated that's about the
ratio of support the idea is getting on
bc radio and on the line in langley hi
anne what do you think
i really think they need to pay their
way
that's despicable to say that it's
despicable to say that you're going to
charge people quite frankly i'm sick and
tired of us collectively being held
hostage by sadly the previous caller who
probably gets his medical advice from
joe rogan if i can't control what's in
my bloodstream then we're not in this
free society anymore this is communism
not a good idea no for or against
whether it's calgary or st catherine
street in montreal this one has people
talking and that may be part of the
reason for the proposal quebec's health
minister says the day the anti-vaxx tax
was announced appointments for first
doses jumped 7 000 people booked whether
it ever happens or not it may already be
having an impact mike armstrong global
news montreal